hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 31 or 3d and
programming in Java alright so last week
we are we made this quick color wise my
mouse blinking screen recorder but why
is it blinking I swear I never noticed
that before anyway arm we made this
quick color thing where we were able to
basically detect stuff based on based on
color and that was really cool so my
mouse stopped blinking that's good so
yeah alright we did that last week and
we're not gonna use that in this episode
but um that theory will actually use to
create levels but before we can create
levels we need to create some basically
some entities for levels to have right
so at the moment we've done as a blocks
all right if we launch our game real
quick then you can see that all we've
got and by the way this mouse thing like
I'm I think I've said it before but
we're not gonna be at we're not gonna do
mouse Y movement in this in this game
alright because it's just it's too
complicated there's no point in doing
that without OpenGL so this will be like
a basically like a dungeon crawler type
game like Wolfenstein 3d or whatever
Doom 1 it won't won't have white mouse
movements so in other words I don't
think it's really necessary to have a
mouse so what I want to do and just
purely up to you I've shown you guys how
to make yourselves a mouse but what I
want to do is I'm just going to
basically change the mouse movement so
that we can actually use the arrow keys
to move around alright so right left
rotation right rotation left will be
left and right so I'm just creating the
controls for that
all right boolean rotation left and
boolean rotation right so in other words
what I want to happen is I'm what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna comment out
the mouse completely you guys can leave
it in okay this is all up to you like if
you guys want a mouse in this game you
can do that I've shown you guys how to
do that
but my personal preference preference is
to advocate board just because you know
it's like an old-style game and it's
cool so if rotation left then let's just
do this
and if right then well let's do the
opposite thing I guess I think that
might work we managed to reverse the
order we'll see and we have to also set
that is lame we have to set this to like
4/4 I'm actually noble will say alright
yep before 4 is looking sharp all right
cool so now we've got him out now we've
got a keyboard controlling our game so
in case you guys wanted to do that yeah
so we've got that now um but what this
tutorial is gonna be focused on is
sprites
all right you probably read it by the
title I'm not gonna spend two hours
explaining that but the point is we've
got we've got blocks right if we launch
our game that's where I stop that's
right
well well when we launch our game we get
you know basically the blocks that we've
created obviously like we can't see one
side of it but if we go into flash level
you can see they're all good
there's no collision yet okay I know
that you guys want collision but what I
mean is like the reason I haven't done
collision yet is I think that it's
impractical
hot and hard and you know again not
necessarily to do collision right now
because of the fact that this is a
randomly generated basically mock-up
world right when we actually do our
collision sorry well when we actually do
our level so we've actually got a level
that we've made ourselves I think I'll
add collision then
right because I don't want to have to
add collision for each individual block
I think I want to do it it for my so
yeah so that's why I haven't had a
collision yet but the thing is we've
only got blocks right we don't have any
sprites now what are sprites sprites are
basically two deep sort of like images I
guess 2d textures right so this stuff at
the moment is 3d right because we can
walk around and we can see it from
different angles it's all cool but 2d
sprites they're always facing the camera
wherever we are
they're always facing you what have to
do is look at them like they don't move
with the camera but what I mean is if
you were to look at them if if there was
like let's just say this corner of this
block right here was a 2d sprite right
if we look at it from this angle it is
still be looking at us if we look at it
from this angle it would still be
looking at us but obviously we turn away
we can't see anymore all right so that's
sort of what a 2d sprite is and that's
what we're sort of going to start today
again I don't really want I don't really
have time to make these episodes very
long I know that I've sort of been
putting out a video every two weeks and
I'm sorry but um I don't know man like
school is just taking up so much time
it's not it's not just school like it's
not like I study 24/7 cuz I don't it's
just that you know the times that I'm
not studying I sort of want to hang out
with my friends and do something fun so
that's why you know I guess this is like
my third priority so my first priority
school my second priority is friends and
fun and stuff and my third priority is
this so yeah that's why I guess um I
haven't been posting that much but in
all honesty school has been taking it up
about 80% of my time so it's ridiculous
um but hey it's last year so like I'm
not even I'm not even joking like next
year oh man you're gonna be sitting I'm
seeing like three videos a day from me
I'm kidding right away I don't want to
put out three videos a day but um but
more videos 'best there'll be tons so
anyway enough talking about me and let's
get on to sprites so what I want to do
first in surprise is potentially I'll
just create a sprite Claus let's go into
graphics into a graphics package and
we'll create a new class for called
sprites and the way we're going to do
this is we're basically gonna use in an
ArrayList all right
so what an ArrayList is is it's
potentially it's sort of like an array
but it's a list so what an ArrayList is
and I'd uh maybe there's a better way to
find out so I'm just gonna open up the
Java the Java doc
oh it's happy happy Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day by the way to every mother
if you guys are watching this today is a
happy Mother's Day to a mother and take
her out for lunch or something because
it's Mother's Day today and not in all
countries actually because I think it's
well it's the 13th of May here but it's
probably still like the 12th of May in
America in America so it's still
Saturday
anyway Java API all right I was hoping
it would being like my history or
something all right cool
sore ArrayList all right yeah it's a
resizable array implementation of list
interface all right so essentially what
an array is is it's something that is
set to be what it is all right so in
other words it's it's got like a set a
set length as it's called right so once
you make an array so in here for example
and render 3d oops or in here anyway we
made a no just go around to 300 yeah
that's fine we made an array of an
integer right we call the pixels and
then we set it equal to width times
height which is 800 times 400 which is
480 thousand right so sorry 800 by 600
there's 480 thousand and that's fine but
see if we try and read the value of 480
thousand and 1 we get an array index out
of bounds exception because we've gone
over the limit but what an array list is
is it's an expandable it's a resizable
array implementation of listen to face
so you guys should really read this I
don't really want to get too deep into
discussing what a-listers but
yeah basically
Oh malecite coz list isn't really
classes at Nantes probably yeah here we
go it's an interface list it's in the
utility package make sure you grab that
one because this list isn't the ought aw
t1 we're looking at the utility one it's
an order collection
all right so in other words what we sort
of want to do and you guys can read up
on that if you want just Google Java
list or whatever but let's happen up the
block class real quick so what I sort of
want to do here is I want to have like
all of my sprites I want them sort of to
be contained within one ordered list
right so let's quickly create a list
we'll make it public and the syntax for
this is we haven't done this before enum
in this series but the syntax for it is
basically you use these less than and
greater than signs right so public lists
sprite so what this is is it's the class
that we're in so we made a sprite class
right here that's what's gonna be in
here sprites that's just the name equals
new ArrayList sprite and then after that
we have to put an almost syntax right so
what we have to do first of all it's
less importantly I'm gonna do this some
manually at list from util ArrayList
we're import that as well if my computer
start starts working import or a list
from here and then sprite you can see
that we have to import our sprite class
that we created alright and that's all
we need to do for imports and now let's
make a method for adding the sprites to
the actual level so all we want to do is
we want to go public void add sprite
we'll call it a sprite and this will
take one parameter and that'll be the
actual sprite class object and all we
want to do is when everyone go sprites
which is this list sprites dot add so
what add does is it basically adds an
element to the end list so it adds
another element into our list so we want
to add
the sprite so essentially when we call
the add sprite method we're gonna be
adding a new sprite into our ArrayList
right so in other words if we've got let
me see it where's my little painting
hairs so if we've got if we want to add
a new sprite let's just say it's this
thing right that thing and we've got
like oh this is our sprites thing then
what happens is when we call add a
sprite method we specify the sprite we
want to add into our game right it's the
sprite that we want to add into the into
the scene so what it does is we say all
right let's let's add our sprite yeah
I'm good at this either you can say we
want to add our sprite so what happens
is we call this method and then it adds
this thing into here all right so now
our level looks like that because we've
added this into here all right hope that
cleared it up and guess you guys ain't
get it you probably did get it by just
by looking at it because you know we're
adding the sprite to our to our list all
right cool
so now we've got that out of the way
let's um let's get into actually
creating these sprites all right so I'm
not gonna do textures today it should be
really easy you guys should be able to
figure it out by yourselves I'll
probably do it next week or something
although I'll do them next week along
with something else as well we might add
like transparency to surprise something
as well next week but um today all we're
gonna do is we're gonna basically do the
same thing that we did with walls first
which is we just created like a plain
color for a wall and then we added you
know stuff all right cool so let's go
back into our sprite thing so actually
let's just open up yeah okay I want to
make a constructor for this which takes
a few per
all I wanted to take is a few doubles so
X double y and double Z all right so
this is basically gonna be like the
location of the sprite on the screen so
I also want to create some global ones
so public double x y&z right and what's
going to happen is when we launch the
constructor it's gonna set this sub X
equal x so let's just do that for each
of them all right explain this in a
minute you guys by the way up there is
nothing explaining like pretty much
everything so in depth right now is
because um I always sometimes I asked
you guys if you want me to go in depth
with this stuff and you said that you
did you know that's why I did the whole
color thing so I'm just saying that in
case there's some like professional like
programmer of something or a game
developer watching this and being like
dude well I already know this stuff well
our cool story bro is what I say to you
because a bunch of you probably like 80%
don't know what I'm talking about so
that's why I'm explaining everything
alright so what we're basically setting
is we're saying we're saying that when
we when we run the constructor right so
when we go new sprite we're creating
well where the parameters are three
values so three doubles so for example
zero zero zero what we're doing is we're
saying that let's set this X to beat
this X right now the reason that we're
doing this is because basically what we
can't access this anywhere right we can
only access these these parameters the
values of these parameters within these
within here right if we want another
method and we want to let's just say
public avoid test or whatever and we
want to like I don't know we want to use
we want to use one of these values that
we've put into here
we can't unless we make a global one and
then we set them equal to this so in
other words in s equals x times xx for
example right that's gonna work because
that's gonna work because X is this X
but we've set it equal to a global X
that we can now use in different methods
as well as in different classes because
it's public alright so that's a quick
reason why we do that and you'll see
that coming to use shortly alright cool
so that's pretty much all we need to do
here actually let's um let's actually go
to our level class and what I want to do
here is just on the here we've got our
we've got our this and then else so what
happens is if basically we're randomly
creating a solid block right and I
actually think there's too many blocks
to be honest it's looking a bit like
we're really full so I might just put
this number up to like eight or
something so that we get less frequent
blocks like that here we go yeah that's
that's better so there's less blocks so
basically one in eight although it's
random but one in eight will be a block
so else so where there's new what where
where there are no solid blocks we want
to create some sprites for example just
just for this just just to basically set
up our sprite system so what I want to
do is I want to just here a block dot
add sprites there's that as bright
method that we created in block to add
surprise to our scene to our level add
sprite and then this probably going to
use is just simply new sprite zero zero
zero all right let's import that this is
terminate this is well I'm not sure why
it's still running I've got to close it
alright cool so now that we've got this
we're basically adding a new sprite to
every single block that isn't solid so
everything every single thing every
single area that isn't a wall now has a
sprite on it now of course we can't see
that sprite because we actually haven't
created it but the point is that's what
we've got at the moment
cool awesome
alright so let's actually go into our
render 3d glasses close this open up our
render 3d class and what we're going to
do is we're essentially going to
copy the render wall method but simplify
it because we don't need it to be 3d
well we do to an extent with its
basically it's called 2.5 D really this
is this is what is called 2.5 T the
sprite is technically in 3d space but no
rotation for it exists it's not
technically a 3d object it's just in 3d
it's a 2d object in 3d space so 2.5 D
and you'll see what I mean once I
actually create it so all I'm gonna do
is I'm essentially gonna copy this
method right so I'm not gonna actually
copy it I'm just gonna go public void
Brenda sprite and all I want to do here
is I'm gonna be really lays in I'm gonna
call them double X double Y and doubles
Zed only three parameters x y&z right so
what we need to do now is essentially
copy our um this sort of stuff so let's
just copy this stuff I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna spend like half an hour
retyping everything that's in here
because there's a lot of code here I'm
just gonna copy and paste a few things
so let's change this to X less chances
to Zed and that's X is right that's good
as that is 4 that's brilliant
and let's okay so we also need all of
our corrects correct data so let's bring
that up here as well and yeah awesome so
that's working cool and we also need to
create one for is for y so I guess I'll
just call this YC and I'm just gonna get
rid of left as well so we don't need
that
so we'll just simplify it and Y is gonna
be essentially the same thing set Y and
up and up correct and again that's just
it alright now we also need to create
our rotation values basically because we
still wanted to rotate as then we still
wanted to rotate in 3d space it's just
the physical object doesn't need to the
actual the actual image doesn't need to
rotate it's
self but its position in 3d space has to
change when we rotate so I'll just call
this X R for X rotation I guess equals
our XC so if you go down like I'm
literally just copying this right if you
go around here or is it it's basically
this let's just grab this actual YZ I'm
gonna retype everything it's it's a bit
different from that but tonight that's
the wrong thing hang on here we go so
basically this right so rotation right
side I'll just call this rotation X
rotation Y and we need one more for
rotation Z all right so this is very
loosely base of rotation so we'll set
this just a tilde Y say that'll be
enough because we're not rotating Y
either
and here what we'll do is again XC
riders now hold X see and in fact this
needs to be Zed C and this should be XC
I'm not sure why that's flips all right
so we got that that's all done now
all right what we need what we need to
do now is create our pixels as we did
before
so here we go we had these things let's
just grab that copy that and we'll paste
it into here make sure you're watching
this full screen of course you'd be
watching every one of my recording
videos of the of this series full screen
but um yeah so if you're not sure what
I'm copying and pasting you just you
know you can recopy it but it should
logically make sense as well so don't
forget don't forget to actually think
about the code that that you're typing
so be like oh yeah I totally get why
that works and if you don't at first
type out all the code and then try and
change values and play around with it
and you'll be like alright well if I
change this to a times four I can see
what happens like you know what I mean
like I can see I can see what that
changed so now I know what this value
does so yeah make sure you're actually
playing around with card and stuff
I'm just gonna call this X pixel in this
one Y pixel and this is gonna be our our
rotation X divided by a rotation said
and this is going to be our rotation Y
divided by rotation Z and we don't need
this but we do need to put it into the
center of our screen so what we're going
to do is the center of our screen is
Center X hang on my width is 800 isn't
it yep so X Center
let's build a strong anyway X Center is
800 divided by 2 which is 400 and our Y
Center I'm just putting a point 0 here
just to make it more precise so I'm sure
you guys know how it works that's an
integer that's a double and in fact if
you if you want to be really straight to
you do that but I'm not going to why
Santa am I told about that in the future
video why Santa is 300 because 600
divided by 2 is 300 so we need to add on
X Center X Center center onto there and
why a center on Y Center on to here
cool so now we need to essentially do
the and I'm gonna actually need to
create the pixels first don'twe yeah
okay okay so double X pixels 0 will be
so basically essentially what we're
doing now is the same thing that we did
here so that we need to do a bunch of
times
oh it's more like this actually anyway
you'll say so
next pixel 0 is gonna equal our x pixel
minus 16 so basically we're gonna make
these 16 by 16 multi-degree will be 32
by 32 but you'll see divided by Z now
our Z values
now I'm not sure what I called it how's
that buffer is best what I'm referring
to you did I call it said wool mm I was
that say that's right / said see and
let's copy this four times so we need to
for the X so in other words again
mister paint.net it's so useful if we've
got a box right if we've got a box and
that's a really bad color that's how you
voice :
that's better if we've got a box we
essentially have just make this a bit
bigger nope 20:28 let's go 20 yet we've
essentially got four corners of it that
we need to map so before before actually
to be honest before we had more because
let me just said this to this color so
that it's consistent before we actually
had more because we had it was three
days so we had this essentially and yeah
so what we had was a five so it was
really good
no hang on that confusing me alright so
let's just make this a bit darker so it
looks 3d there we go
I'm talking about all right cool so what
we had before essentially was this sort
of deal this sort of deal where we add
all this to do and then these ones as
well all right so that was a bit of a
confusing thing but now basically we're
cutting all that and we're saying once
whoops we're cutting all that and what
what the hell I selected that we're
cutting all that and was saying you know
it's um it's all good because we're 2d
so what we need is four of these one
fresh corner so
I'm doing here as I'm saying that X
pixels zero is this thing in fact I
might just just spin to see am i I might
hold is that all right son this is why
pixel so essentially I'm saying that on
the x axis this is gonna be it's gonna
be one that's gonna be true and it's
gonna be once cuiture so left right left
right cool awesome
and so that's going to be plus sixteen
and then this is gonna be the same thing
minus and plus all right and that's it
all right now what we need to do is the
same thing that we did here pixels are
not doubles pixels they're integers so
like we over here like we cast why do we
do that like we did over here we cast
these two an integer we need to do the
same thing here so we need to basically
create xpl so oops make sure it's an
integer X BL so X P L is going to be X
pixel left in be integer version of it
so X so int X pixel left and again I'm
just going to go ahead and copy and
paste out a few times
and call this X pixel right and then
there's why pixel left and wipe it's
alright and let's just change this and
you should you have that alright cool
so now we have to deal with clipping
again so don't forget this
I've got like a felt like a little like
notepad in front of me with like with
steps in order to do that it's like as
in you know create the actual rotation
values then create the create the the
corner pins and then create and then
cause them to integers and then do
clipping so um I'm following like a
little list in front of me
so X pixels 0 which we call Dec special
right left actually if X pixel left is
less than 0 and then clip it so make it
equal to 0 and then let's copy this a
bunch of times
three more times actually Xbox all right
if it's greater than the width of our
frame then so left is only he's
obviously only gonna beat zero because
zero is left of our screen and and our
max values on the right of our screen
the width is on the right of our screen
then let's set that equal to width make
sure you are saying this is equal to
width and why if that's that then let's
make this greater so they're equal to
width all right so again this is just
really simple clipping that you have to
do all the time and it's very common all
right cool so now let's create our loop
that will actually render this so for
int M
I'll call it wipe a straw for white
pixel equals y pixel so we're gonna
render from the left to the right side
so I pixel L left Y PL and if Y pay is
less than our right value
so we're rendering all the way through
the right value of course and again
let's just copy and paste this and
rename this to X X X I'm gonna yep X X
Oh make sure your X pay plus plus not y
plus plus or white papers plus so you're
actually adding it onto this one because
we do actually have a variable called Y
and that's right here so make sure
you're not doing that although I said in
otherwise it will not work alright so if
our Z buffer which yep all right cool so
if al Z buffer is where am I Aaron if as
that buffer of x p+ y pixel times width
is greater than ours Zed
and I think I was looking wrong
shouldn't this be this should be the
rotation value my bad
oops good thing I saved that as in yeah
alright greater than a set rotation
value then let's actually render it so
or what we need to do when he has had
pixels of again this equal to a color so
when I've been color picker calm and do
this cool so I'm thinking like a look on
those royal blue color cuz I like that
color maybe like this that calls nice
alright cool and again we did the same
thing for our Z buffer we a set it equal
to zero rotations that cool awesome so
now we've done this we need to correct
for walking huh we'll do that in a
minute I just want to say this works
first alright so actually yeah it's
right off to here so if it yeah it's
right it's right under here let's just
go ahead and create it so we need to
make a we need to make a a for loop to
handle to to work its way through all
the values in our list so ass for sprite
equals zero sprite value is less than
block so blockers we're just taking it
from here
block dot sprites dot size so the same
thing as like if we created I'll show
you guys in a minute actually
alright so it's the same thing as if
we're saying that we create an integer
an array integer called SD and it's
equal to
whatever all right there's values all
right then if we go for and SD SD SSD
solid state drive equals zero SSD is
less than s d dot length right so
basically what we're saying is if it's
like if it's less than the length of all
these well in arraylists they're called
size instead of length so that's how
that works
another thing on arraylists then let's
actually render sprite so right we'll
use this method obviously render sprite
and we're going to render it out X block
plus plus our sprite ax o when you
create the object first sprite sprite
equals we'll get the sprites block don't
surprise don't get so again that's gonna
get an eye it's gonna get all of the our
sprites and we call it s so block so
sprite dot X so again that's why we
created these ones so that we could use
it and we also need to do the same thing
so sprite dot y and z block plus spread
out why all that should be Zed probably
will say all right let's launch this and
see if it works cool so we definitely
got some sprites and they don't seem to
be working correctly
well that ok rotation something's wrong
with rotation so the most well we've got
a surprise on every single block though
leather black colors like the exact same
is the thing let's make like a red color
let's just go let's just go red yeah so
what am i doing I'm sitting the college
for red that's right so what is it
FF alright ok cool ok first of all we're
getting some really annoying like
clipping right here like that's not
getting clipped and the reason for that
is because four actually
oh that crashed okay why don't that
crash right is that a bounds for ya
alright cool so a lot of problems here
at the moment but not bad for a first
try
first of all let's yeah alright so the
reason we actually need a okay let's
okay let's fix this first let's fix the
problem of um okay so that is why
properly either that just makes it
frickin crash and so crouching Mesa
crash and we're not getting any it's
getting cut off here even though it
shouldn't be so there we go it's been
cut off because things are rendering in
front of it so to make sure that where
that the the sprites the last thing that
we actually render let's basically what
what I want to do is I want to copy this
and let's go back to the end of the for
loop so right over here and let's cut
this and put it into this full loop
and that should solve that problem
awesome it did yeah you can see how that
worked we've also got another problem
first of all walking obviously the
surprise door in Bob up but don't bob up
and down with the walking room like
there should let's fix that first though
that actually should have already fixed
itself so that's why I'm I'm wondering
why I didn't see exactly going too far
up they should be if they weren't if it
wasn't happening they would have stayed
let's try and reverse up correct oh that
worked that work too crashed it would
have worked so what's the deal here what
happened with the array index out of
bounds nothing's out of bounds
what exactly is out of bounds let's say
let's diagnose this all right um
rotations said seems to is that buffer
seems to be out of bounds guessing it is
that buffer that seems fine though huh
width is 800 about 600 that's 655 what
it's our bounds huh it's because it's
causing this because of that it's
because they go out of Bounce
shouldn't we have fixed that actually
let's take a look at this good I'm
thinking it clipping should have oh my
bad
all right say make sure this is height
not width
obviously let's check that out
let's see if that fixed it oh yeah okay
we don't crash anymore and that works
just really cool so now well I don't not
sure why we had to reverse it but it
works now and you can see that we've
actually got a sprite for every single
block right cool right yeah it is cool
and it looks Oh world rotation isn't
exactly working well first of all we're
not getting any any darkness here so it
should be getting darker so let's
increase our rotation I said basically
let's not call this rotations it uh-huh
yeah all right so let's just increase
this by like I don't know eight times
there we go that looks kind of nice
doesn't it that was brilliant
that's nice all right cool and let's
also
huh I'm just wondering why rotation
isn't working look at that oh hang on a
minute
damn look at this
that's works that works doesn't it that
seems to work at least huh
I'm thinking let's um let's let's just
the walking so I should just be by the
way we're just walking with the walls
obviously it's because we add it
walking times walking correct so plus
walking times a warp correct oh let's
put this time stir into the back okay
that didn't work let's reverse it
whoops let's some reverse this won't do
our thing all right that did work yeah
you can see they're glued to the wall
now except with that that didn't work
okay uh-huh
but this should be zero right now so it
shouldn't be should it no it shouldn't
be we didn't we shouldn't have to
reverse the OP they're not definitely
not all right interesting interesting
and I'm pretty sure within your release
yeah now we don't all right interesting
all right cool what other things so our
rotation is still really buggy look at
that well that that's definitely not
right the least cells that buffer is
working properly there so I wonder why
that's happening
I'm just checking up all of this for
consistency just making sure that
everything's right laughter I love
trying stammers yeah this controls the
size of the sprites by the way so we can
make them like 128 large and then if we
say that you can see that you know got
very big sprites so there we go what's
correctly here doesn't it that's fine
but then if we turn here look at that
that's awful
so something to do with everything not
working probably except for this stuff
huh all right les wants to take a look
at this car to make sure everything's
everything's correct okay um so that's
right that is right
and
oh that should be plus and there we go
oh my gosh now say that simple error in
plus or minus and you get something
entirely different
cool awesome slow less changes back to
something smaller like 32 or something
so 32 is is actually gonna make him 64 H
which is fine as a good size of sprites
and that seems to be working let's find
one that's in the wall
not exactly good is that because of
walking corrector or that because of up
correct I'm not sure they seem to lift a
bit so it's almost as if approach is too
much they make it worse
yeah it's getting a bit better
because this one's right in the wall
isn't it so it needs to just stay in the
wall not too much
all right now it's looking perfect yep
that's perfect
all right cool so that's a lot better
we've got flawless sprites now on every
sickle block so yeah as you can see that
every okay and you can also see how
they're facing that what time are we out
45 minutes while were you kidding me
that we were like 20 minutes Wow time
flies anyway oh okay
yeah so you can see how they're always
facing the camera so if I start rotating
and stuff they're still facing me so
that's how that sort of works now you
can see that we've got one on every
single block alright so let's try and
make them on on every like five blocks
or whatever one in every five blocks or
something on there let's say that if
random dot next oops and five equals
zero so same thing as we did here then
let's rent let's do this alright cool so
now they're a lot more rare looks nice
doesn't it brilliant
cool awesome
this looks awesome okay so we've got
sprites now and next week we'll probably
add textures fit to them and maybe even
transparency so part of them can be
transparent and and then after that I
guess we'll just start adding a leveled
we'll start making levels so yeah I hope
you enjoyed this episode of 3d game
programming Java this feels really
formal on a kind of thing you should so
yeah leave some feedback down below and
maybe even start submitting like game
didn't like game design like game game
gameplay I don't know what called game
like story ideas I think I was like this
is beginning to take place this is
beginning this is sort of beginning to
take shape into like what we want the
game to actually you know be about I
guess and what the gameplay will be like
and where it's gonna be set et cetera et
cetera
so maybe start living comments about
that I don't know we're not up to that
said yet but we are nearing it as you
can see so yeah the other thing was hit
the like button let's get 200 likes we
did that last week we know that this
week as well and it makes me feel all
warm inside when we when we were aged
that so so I'm hit the like button if
you enjoy this video and if we get 200
likes and we will we will do textures
basically there is no I'm asking for
likes is what that is it does help me
out first of all it sort of rewards me I
guess for my good work and then the the
second reason is that um you know I'm so
busy with school that if there's you
know if I guess I guess I feel that if
not enough people are actually
benefiting from my videos then or you
know whatever are enjoying my videos
then you know I shouldn't I shouldn't
basically take a day off school pretty
much well not really but you know take a
day off studying basically to to make an
episode it's not enough people are
enjoying it that's why it that's that's
just that sort of why I that's my
mindset behind it but um yeah so please
hit the like button and if we had if we
get to 200 lifes and will continue with
sprites and move on to level design in
the next few episodes so yeah I'll see
you guys later bye